il est 20h bonsoir à tous bon début de
week-end voici les titres de l'actualité
plus que jamais les questions demeurent
sur la disparition du vol 447 d'air
france
les débris retrouvés par l'armée
brésilienne ne sont finalement pas ceux
de l'appareil
l'énigme reste donc entière ce soir
barack obama est en route pour la france
le président américain était aujourd'hui
en allemagne avec une visite symbolique
dans le camp de buchenwald en normandie
les cérémonies du 65e anniversaire du
débarquement ont commencé mais le jour j
c'est bien sûr pour demain j - deux en
revanche pour les élections européennes
en france à suivre les derniers sondages
et puis les dernières tensions aussi
entre daniel cohn bendit et françois
bayrou leurs formations apparaissent au
coude à coude dans les intentions de
vote
à suivre également richard gasquet qui
sort de son silence et qui contre
attaque
trois semaines après les révélations sur
son contrôle positif à la cocaïne
le tennisman français affirme n'avoir
jamais touché à cette drogue
il a décidé de porter plainte vous
l'entendrez ce soir enfin c'est un
événement à dimension planétaire que
nous allons vivre ensemble ce soir le
film home de yann arthus bertrand va
être diffusée dans plus de 120 pays et
sur france 2 il interpelle 7 milliards
d'individus
le réalisateur sera avec nous à ses
côtés françois henri pinault également
luc besson ses partenaires dans cette
aventure
merci d'être avec nous et l'énigme
persiste donc ce soir après cinq jours
de recherches
aucune trace aucune pièce de l'airbus
d'air france n'a été finalement retrouvé
au milieu de l'atlantique on a appris
aujourd'hui que l'armée brésilienne
s'était quelque peu précipitée en
annonçant que les débris qu'elle avait
récupéré en mer appartenait à l'avion
disparu
ce n'est donc pas le cas de quoi
alimenter bien sûr encore et toujours
des questions
claude son père voici les toutes
dernières images diffusées par la
télévision brésilienne
les images de l'armée de l'air commenté
avec beaucoup de prudence le journaliste
parle de débris dans l'eau mais sans
jamais dire qu'il s'agit de débris de
l'avion cinq jours après la disparition
du vol d'air france le mystère reste
entier
la nuit dernière s'est produit un coup
de théâtre
après avoir annoncé la découverte d'un
premier débris de l'avion une partie de
la soute à bagages le porte parole de
l'armée a fait machine arrière et fait
cadeau comme à terre après vérification
les débris retrouvés n'appartiennent pas
l'avion français
il s'agit d'une palette en bois utilisé
par les bateaux de pêche
on en trouve parfois sur les avions mais
dans le vol de paris
il n'y avait pas de palettes en bois cet
après-midi des familles de victimes sont
arrivés à recife au nord du brésil
elles ont voulu rencontrer les
militaires qui participent aux
opérations de recherche
car ils en ont assez d'entendre des
informations contradictoires
on a appris par exemple aujourd'hui que
les fameuses nappe de pétrole
photographié à deux reprises à la
surface de l'eau seraient en fait des
résidus de pollution de bateaux et non
pas le kérosène de l'avion en clair
jusqu'à aujourd'hui aucun débris de
l'avion n'a encore été récupérés et de
multiples questions demeurent où l avion
personne ne sait les brésiliens ont déjà
ratisser une zone de 185 mille
kilomètres carrés un tiers de la france
aucune épave n'a été localisé quelles
sont les causes de la disparition
personne ne sait or h foudre grêle givre
explosion d intégration tout cela n'est
que spéculation seule certitude d'après
le bureau enquête analyse on sait
simplement que les messages envoyés par
l'avion indique l'incohérence des
vitesses mesurées
pour quelles raisons mystère aujourd'hui
airbus a recommandé aux équipages de
suivre les consignes en cas de
défaillance des indicateurs de vol en
clair si l'équipage rencontre de fortes
turbulences
il doit maintenir une vitesse suffisante
alors l'enquète on l'a bien compris est
plus que fragile pour le moment à paris
une information judiciaire a été ouverte
contre x pour homicide involontaire
autres faits du jour
la france a décidé d'envoyer sur place à
un sous marin en tout cas les recherches
poursuivre dans une vaste zone qui est
vous allez loire quadrillé
progressivement par l'armée française
dominique derda frédéric ranquet et
frédéric guiraud
cinq jours déjà qu'ils patrouillaient
toujours rien à l'horizon pendant près
de trois heures au large du brésil
l'équipage du bréguet atlantique va
passer au peigne fin une zone de
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres carrés
juste au nord de celle où les brésiliens
10 et hier encore avoir découvert des
morceaux de l'airbus
cet avion à l'origine a été conçu pour
traquer les sous-marins ennemis autant
dire qu'à son bord ces spécialistes ont
le regard acéré
pourtant même le nez collé à la vitre
même à 30 mètres à peine au dessus de
l'eau malgré leurs instruments des plus
performants aujourd'hui encore ils sont
rentrés bredouilles depuis le début de
leur mission sur les traces du vol af
les militaires français n'ont encore
trouvé aucun indice
ça va être un peu décevante c'est pas
forcément ça veut dire qu'elle contrôle
aérien donc c'est une information
enquêtes importantes - la zone je les ai
couvert très bonnes conditions je sais
qu'à rien donc on va déplacer nos zones
est et la recherche c'est ça il faut
être patient et méthodique la patience
la méthode et les moyens aussi à très
haute altitude cet avion radar awacs
voit non seulement coordonner les
recherches mais aussi tenter d'établir
une carte des débris éventuels
on s'inscrit dans la continuité il faut
que les bateaux mais moyens maritimes
notamment bateau et sous marins arrive
sur zone ont donc c'est ce qu'on attend
maintenant
en plus de ce qui a été une couverture
aérienne qui va continuer bien sûr la
couverture aérienne parce qu'on peut
toujours espérer trouver quelque chose
qu'on surfe aussi sur la base aérienne
de dakar les rotations se succèdent à un
rythme de plus en plus soutenus pas
question pour les militaires français
baisser la garde ils sont déterminés à
retrouver au plus vite les restes de
l'appareil pour l'anc est bien sûr mais
aussi du style pour les familles des
passagers et des membres d'équipage
alors prenons maintenant la direction de
l'île de fernando de norohna située à
300 km de la côte brésilienne c'est là
bas que se trouve la base avancée des
opérations de recherche et c'est là bas
que nous retrouvons notre envoyé spécial
lionel feierstein bonsoir l'ena elle
d'abord un mot de ses recherches elle se
poursuivent toujours ce soir
effectivement elles se poursuivent
toutes les deux heures des avions de
reconnaissance se dirige vers le point
d'impact supposé de l'avion à 600
kilomètres d'ici alors pour les aider
dans ces recherches qui pour l'instant
ne sont pas fructueuse la france a
décidé d'envoyer un sous marin nucléaire
alors pourquoi un sous marin nucléaire
tout simplement parce qu à son bord il
dispose d'un sonar qui devrait lui
permettre de détecter ces fameuses
boîtes noires temps nécessaire à l
enquête
et puis on a appris qu'un petit groupe
de familles de victimes a pu quitter rio
à destination de recife
aujourd'hui c'est cela effectivement les
familles des victimes brésiliennes se
sont rendus à recife une dizaine de
personnes au quartier général des forces
armées brésiliennes elles ont rencontré
des militaires qui leur ont expliqué
qu'effectivement aucun débris de
l'appareil n'avait été repêché alors
vous imaginez qu avec tous ces
revirements
les familles sont excédés elles ont
désormais l'intention de suivre de très
très près l'anc est une façon aussi de
mettre la pression sur les autorités
brésiliennes
merci et lionel et à demain dans
l'actualité également les élections
européennes on voit d'où le savez ce
dimanche en france on va parler la
tension qui est montée d'un cran hier
soir sur le plateau d'à vous de juger
mais d'abord un dernier sondage celui de
tns sofres logica pour france
télévisions le monde radio france
l'ump reste stable à 27 % le ps pas sous
les 20% et c'est la liste europe
écologie qui occupe la troisième place
avec 15 5% devant le modem à 12
gül 5% alors faut-il y voir une relation
de cause à effet la lutte pour la
troisième place semble se jouer entre
les listes du modem de françois bayrou
et celle de daniel cohn bendit en tout
cas la tension est donc montée d'un cran
je vous le disais entre les deux hommes
hier soir sur france 2 lors de
l'émission d'arlette chabot et les
nuques et toi ces deux là faisait
estrade commune pour le oui au
référendum en 2005
les voilà désormais concurrent daniel
cohn bendit a pris l'avantagé en étions
d'âge de quoi énerver françois bayrou
qu'il accuse de complicité avec nicolas
sarkozy
vous êtes venu déjeuner trois fois à
l'elysée entend avec tous les présidents
dont le président de tout mal
je me sens pas mal je trouve ça ignoble
de ta part et bien mon pote je te dis
jamais tu seras président de la
république a bien parce que t'es trop
minable très bien trop minable je ne
suis pas sûr que vous puissiez vous
employer le mot ignominie je trouve
ignoble moi d'avoir poussé et justifié
des actes à l'égard des enfants que je
ne peux accepter sûr que tu es bien là
dessus allusion à un livre publié en
1975 par l'ancien leader de mai 68 sur
la sexualité des enfants livre donc il
avait déjà regretté la teneur il ya huit
ans peu après le débat daniel cohn
bendit a réagi et quand je crois qu'il a
dépassé les limites il a pété les plombs
de ce pugilat il a évidemment été
question dans les derniers meetings de
campagne pour la droite
françois bayrou a dérapé cette façon de
faire de la politique de la part de
françois bayrou mais coeur il a
totalement perdu son sang froid
or en politique un responsable peut être
serein à gauche c'est l'indignation en
appel à tout le monde à la dignité des
débats
je crois que l'europe mérite mieux que
des attaques personnelles moi c'est pas
ma conception de la politique
moi je n'ai qu'un adversaire c'est l'ump
n'ont pas les hommes et les femmes et
leurs idées et je pense qu'il faut
rester jusqu'au bout de ligne du combat
qui est le nôtre terne jusqu'ici la
campagne européenne vient en tout cas de
se réveiller
à quelques heures du mat alors est-ce
que la tension d'hier était retombé
aujourd'hui et bien françois bayrou est
revenu sur ce face à face et apparemment
il assume cette polémique en l'écoutant
je ne pratique pas la politique des
regrets de se retourner en arrière
cet incident a eu lieu il veut dire
quelque chose je suis pas que je vais
pas prétendre devant vous que c'était un
accident ou quelque chose je crois que
ça a du sens je crois que ça de la
signification
g j'ai trouvé ce livre bouleversant en
tout cas il m'a bouleversée mois comme
odieux comme insupportable dans dans
cette vision de l'enfance mon intention
n'était pas du tout de l'évoquer mais
c'est l'explosion dans laquelle nous
étions qui a entraîné cette irruption
mais je ne vous dirai pas que je
regrette d'avoir ressenti ce que j'ai
ressenti dieu et sa cheikh le scrutin a
déjà commencé dans plusieurs pays
européens matière aux pays bas avec une
poussée n'est que sannois de vote en
irlande en tchéquie et en angleterre
l'angleterre qui est en pleine crise
politique le premier ministre gordon
brown se retrouvent obligés d'effectuer
un remaniement ministériel
sept de ses ministres ont décidé de
démissionner suite notamment au scandale
des notes de frais de son côté barack
obama arrivera à paris dans moins d'une
heure maintenant il sera rejoint par son
épouse et leurs deux filles demain à
vous le savez il se rendre en normandie
pour la commémoration du 65e
anniversaire du débarquement allié
il est aujourd'hui en allemagne avec une
visite forte et symbolique celle du camp
de concentration de buchenwald
on voit seul avec berne
lebrun la porte d'entrée du camp est
demeurée intacte en mémoire des
cinquante six mille personnes mortes six
victimes de la barbarie nazie
jamais un président américain n'avait
visité ce lieu barack obama 48 ans
manifestement très ému avait
spécialement demandé à s'y rendre
accompagné de la chancelière angela
merkel mais aussi du prix nobel de la
paix elie wiesel et du français bertrand
herz tous deux anciens déportés
le président s'est longuement recueillis
sur ce mémorial cette visite sur le plan
politique au lendemain du discours du
caire au monde musulman se veut un
message d'amitié à israël est un
avertissement à ceux qui nient la shoah
le président iranien en particulier même
de nos jours il y a ceux qui affirment
que l'holocauste n'a jamais eu lieu à
cet endroit le démenti absolu de ces
idées chez saks temps il nous rappelle
que nous devons affronter ceux qui
falsifient notre histoire à baraka le 11
avril 1945 à 15h15 le temps s'est arrêté
pour l'humanité les troupes américaines
venait de libérer leur premier camp de
concentration y découvrait
l'inimaginable l'indicible
le général eisenhower obligera les
notables de la ville voisine de weimar à
visiter buchenwald qu'il disait ne pas
connaître dans les troupes américaines
présentes se trouvaient le grand oncle
maternel du président obama charlie
payne
aujourd'hui âgé de 84 ans est revenu de
la guerre en état de choc il ne parlait
plus
il est resté seul pendant des mois à
l'écart de sa famille de ses amis
moyenne soit seul avec ses souvenirs
douloureux qu'il tentait barack obama
voulait comprendre le silence de son
monde
buren valent en allemand veut dire
forêts de hêtres elie wiesel de dire au
président si seulement les arbres
pouvait parler
une chose est sûre la normandie est
prête une nouvelle fois accueillir ces
commémorations on attend bien évidemment
les vétérans alliés mais aussi ce
président américain dont tout le monde
parle on soit julien pieds-noirs et
virginie travers et non ce n'est pas
encore air force one qui survol des
plages de normandie
tout le monde l'attend barack obama il
arrive demain les normands se contente
pour l'instant d'une affiche avant de le
voir en chair et en os mais la ville a
déjà son slogan yes we camp jeune belge
est là d'art comme il faut et de mémoire
de normand on n'avait jamais vu autant
de curieux de passionnés débarqué pour
les cérémonies
j'avais pas vu autant depuis le 60ème
anniversaire mais à cinq ans donc voila
quoi ma vie ça ça joue un rôle quand
même
mais le obama arrivé perdu des chez lui
je pense qu'on essaie lui oui
pour accueillir comme un comme un ami
commun
comment un libérateur et comme à la
libération les normands sortent les
drapeaux en signe de bienvenue aux
américains les habitants de colleville
sur mer ont mis la main à la pâte pour
honorer les vétérans et attirer l'oeil
du président allez à votre avis obama va
voir tout ça dans le petit village de
sainte mère église 800 soldats
américains sont stationnés
une aubaine pour le quartier barack
obama dans leur avancée on va même pas
le voir il va s'arrêter devant le monde
entier aura les yeux braqués sur barack
obama et par là même sur la normandie
alors des normands aux vétérans on
répète jusqu'aux derniers mois il y aura
donc beaucoup de monde sur les plages
d'omaha beach et d'août affiche demain
pour certains vétérans ce rendez vous
était devenu une sorte de pèlerinage
annuel
le temps passe et ils sont bien sûr de
moins en moins nombreux à se retrouver
rencontre avec des hommes et leur
mémoire aujourd'hui avec arnaud goûter
et olivier robert la chaise roulante
l'uniforme et les médailles attire les
poignées de main les héros d'hier accède
au rang de star multiplie les
autographes et malgré leur âge se
permettent encore quelques face ici vous
vous souvenez de mon mari
je me souviens surtout de vous des
cérémonies par dizaines hier au
cimetière militaire de colleville
aujourd'hui dans la commune d'isigny
chacune de leur visite est une fête
les vétérans reçoivent un hommage appuyé
en normandie on nous considère comme les
gens normaux alors que partout dans le
monde se sert de l'indonésie les gens
nous avons et il faut les voir lorsque
leurs amis français les accueille dans
la région ils demeurent lé grand
libérateur
je dis souvent comme beaucoup de
normands n'auront jamais fini de vous
dire merci
la fleur au fusil la normandie reçoit
demain le président américain un de plus
pour ces vétérans qui parfois photo en
main affichent clairement leur
préférence
là c'est moi avec george bush et sa
femme à la maison blanche le 3 décembre
2001 il y à un autre président qui vient
demain oui obama et il est mieux que le
précédent
oh ne me posais pas cette question moi
je suis très conservateur mais demain
les vétérans seront tous là par devoir
et patriotisme une nouvelle fois au
garde à vous alors voyons maintenant
comment la journée de demain se prépare
ce 6 juin 2009 à colleville sur mer on
trouve isabelle staes bonsoir isabelle
la journée sera dense et le dispositif
de sécurité
et j'imagine assez important mais déjà
dès ce soir c'est toute la normandie qui
a changé d'aspect et d'ambiance dans
chaque village on a sorti les couleurs
américaines vos côtés des drapeaux
français mais aussi britanniques et sur
chaque route dans chaque rue on croise
des dizaines de djib de soldats
américains mais aussi de passionnés du
débarquement en uniformes de l'époque on
a vraiment l'impression que l'on tourne
à nouveau le jour le plus long ici alors
demain matin après un an un tête à tête
politique entre nicolas sarkozy et
barack obama le temps fort de la journée
ce sera dans l'après midi
ici à colleville lorsque les deux
présidents rendront hommage aux soldats
qui ont débarqué il ya 65 ans dans des
conditions
épouvantable notamment ici sur cette
plage derrière moi la légendaire omaha
beach deux heures de cérémonie sont
prévenus dans le cimetière militaire où
reposent dix mille soldats c'est une
enclave américaine sur le sol français
des milliers d'invités ils sont attendus
dont 200 vétérans américains qui sont
venus tout spécialement des états unis
pour assister à la cérémonie dans le
seul problème ce sera pour les normands
la circulation totalement impossible et
sachez enfin que effectivement le
dispositif de sécurité sera très
important puisque 3000 hommes ont été
mobilisées dont 500 américain pour le
seul président obama merci isabelle et à
demain donc est parmi les premières
cérémonies quais sont déroulés à la
veille de ce 65e anniversaire du d'idées
en voici une qui avait un sens
particulier elle s'est déroulée ce matin
au cimetière de là quand il s'agissait
d'un hommage à tous ceux qui se sont
battus sur les plages qu'ils soient
canadiens américains anglais mais aussi
vous allez le voir allemande soldats
year et des hommes aujourd'hui qui se
sont souvenus ensemble amaury guibert et
mathieu nyberg le ski ils ont aussi leur
place sur le sol de normes anti 700
soldats allemands enterré au cimetière
de la corde
roady et cher a vu ses camarades tombés
par dizaines
il fut aussi l'un des premiers à avoir
les américains débarqués dans la nuit du
5 au 6 juin 44 lui sa section sont en
position à sainte mère église quand
l'alerté donnée
ces montants là vu le premier avion il
est premier parachute
l'idée ne m'est pas venu que ça pouvait
être le début de l'invasion
mais rudi hesher et ses hommes vont
faire face à la déferlante alliés
soldats de la wehrmacht aux ordres du
régime nazi mais soldats avant j'étais
jeune enthousiaste
peut-être que nous sommes leurs et ne
sais pas mais c'était comme ça on ne
peut pas revenir en arrière
être en paix avec le passé ce matin au
cimetière de la cambe les ennemis d'hier
se sont retrouvés
j'ai été fait prisonnier de guerre par
les américains et moi j'ai été
prisonnier de guerre en allemagne
quelques mots échangés et le même état
d'esprit
c'est bien qu'on soit ami qu on oublie
le passé qu'on pense au futur
plus jamais ça et la sonnerie aux morts
leur a rappelé que cette amitié et celle
des survivants
et puis soyons rendez vous demain dès
11h sur france 2 pour une émission
spéciale en direct avec marie drucker à
toutes nos équipes vous proposons de
suivre cet événement il est 20h 19 à
suivre dans un instant cette alerte
orange aux risques d'orages violents
dans une dizaine de départements du
limousin de l'auvergne et la région midi
pyrénées et puis richard gasquet qui
plaide non coupable qui portent plainte
après avoir été convaincu de dopage à la
cocaïne enfin pourquoi ne doit-on pas
manquer home ce soir sur france 2 est un
peu partout dans le monde
eh bien on posera la question à l'équipe
du film yann arthus bertrand luc besson
et françois henri pinault qui seront
avec nous mais avant cela donc après
trois semaines de silence richard
gasquet a choisi de contre attaquer
contrôlé positif à la cocaïne à miami et
menacé de deux ans de suspension le
tennisman français a pris la parole et
il nie avoir consommé de la cocaïne
il a même décidé de porter plainte a
longtemps hésité régis mater
richard gasquet brise le silence pour la
première fois depuis son contrôle
positif à la cocaïne jamais pris de
cocaïne de ma vie ça c'est un truc c'est
une heure pas possible de la cocaïne
donc c'est sûr que ça j'ai vraiment pas
que ce qui m'est arrivé ça a été
vraiment un très très mauvais signe pour
moi et ça l'est encore
le tennisman français donne sa version
des faits sur sa nuit passée dans cette
discothèque à miami le 28 mars dernier
j'ai revu une personne qui était que cet
ascète cette soirée là bas elle m'a dit
que tenait le proposer de la cocaïne qui
avaient énormément de côté qui circulait
ce soir là donc malheureusement
mont-joli pas jugeons comprenez bien que
si je l'avais vue serait vraiment partie
de cette boîte là ça c'est sûr des
propos sous contrôle de ses conseillers
avocats avec lesquels gasquet a décidé
de déposer plainte contre x pour
administration de substance nuisible
selon lui les traces de cocaïne
retrouvées dans ses urines proviendrait
d'une contamination extérieure par un
baiser ou un ver infecte et une version
qui suscite le scepticisme des
spécialistes est-ce que de la cocaïne
peut être absorbé lors d'un baiser lors
d'un verre à ma connaissance il n'y a
pas eu de communication scientifique sur
ce sujet jusqu'à présent tout peut être
envisagé mais par définition
l'exceptionnel n'est pas le plus
probable le 29 juin prochain gasquet
devra apporter la fois pour son
innocence au tribunal anti-dopage le
français risque jusqu'à deux ans de
suspension
et puis sachez que météo france a donc
lancé un bulletin d'alerté orange pour
des risques d'orage violent et cela dans
le limousin l'auvergne et le
midi-pyrénées prudence donc
dans les heures à venir comme un message
d' alerte aux habitants de la planète
c'est je vous le disais tout à l'heure
l'événement ce soir le film home sera
diffusé sur france 2 tout comme dans
près de 120 pays dans le monde un film
en forme de documents pour nous et pour
les générations à venir
la terre est en danger pour nous parler
de tout cela yann arthus bertrand
françois henri pinault et puis luc
besson en duplex les trois partenaires
de cette aventure incroyable bonsoir à
tous les trois merci d'être avec nous
d'abord on y est dans quelques minutes
des millions de téléspectateurs vont
découvrir dans ce film
qu'est ce que vous ressentez yann arthus
bertrand on travaille on travaille
tellement c'est plus à toi à quoi sa
part sa part ailleurs et ce film il
était fait pour ça pourrait vu par la
maximum de gens donc gégousse avait
justement combien de personnes vont dans
les mois qui viennent dont 120 pays
c'est ça mais 120 pays je croyais 85
télévision prime time
il ya un million de connexions sur
youtube de gens qui ont regardé le film
c'est les mêmes les salles de ces
feuillets des salles de cinéma sont
ouverts c'est génial parce que des
exploitants ont accepté d'ouvrir le des
salles de cinéma alors qu'ils étaient
aussi à la télévision avec gratuit voilà
un film gratuit et les salles se
remplissent donc c'est génial françois
henri pinault qu'est ce qui vous a
séduit d'abord dans ce projet du coup tu
sais quand vous avez deux personnalités
comme yann luc besson qui viennent vous
voir talent professionnalisme ensemble
une idée géniale
dès le début qui était la gratuité vous
le savez la gratuité coûte cher et là le
rôle de ppr est un peu plus chère
effectivement oui puis notre rôle on
était à l'époque en 2007 le groupe
s'engage est vrai de façon très très
importante dans la voie du développement
durable
c'était l'opération qu'il nous manquait
pour pouvoir aller encore plus loin en
dix minutes la décision était prise
alors bon soir luc besson vous êtes en
duplex du champ de mars à paris où sera
projeté le film à à 22 heures je crois
vous avez déjà vécu beaucoup d' aventure
mais celle-là j'imaginais a quand même
eu une saveur particulière c'est
vraiment le fait d'accompagner liane
dans ce message je suis un citoyen
tout le monde je savais pas trop quoi
faire comme comme geste écologique pour
servir ma planète
yann est venu me voir avec cette belle
idée je me suis senti plus utile puisque
je connais un petit peu le cinéma donc
je les aider à réaliser son rêve
là il ya déjà à peu près dix mille
personnes à peu près à vue de nez au
champ de mars
donc je pense que ça va ça va être un
beau spectacle alors c'est vrai que vous
n'étiez pas tout à fait d'accord sur le
titre du film je crois avec yann arthus
bertrand c'est vrai oui on sait pas très
bien ce qui risque est important c'est
surtout le message qu'ils véhiculent et
je fais une petite parenthèse par
rapport au cinéma ce que vous dites
les salles ont joué le jeu aujourd'hui
vendredi jusqu'à 22h les gens peuvent
aller le voir enceintes toutes les
salles ne sont pas gratuites
il ya des salles qui font alain hiff
réduit d'autres gratuits pour les
enfants gratuit pour tout le monde ça
dépend des salles voilà donc faut
vérifier quand même avant d'y aller
sinon france 2 dans une demi heure et
vous êtes tous le bienvenu au champ de
mars
allez on va regarder d'ailleurs quelques
images en forme d'avant première de
votre travail
on regarde cela avec gilles marini
c'est notre maison commune la terre vue
du ciel par yann arthus-bertrand paysage
couleurs faune habitat hommes ils sont
surpris dans leur quotidien par cette
caméra fixe et un hélicoptère est
capable de pivoter dans toutes les
directions et maintenant un 360 degrés
autour de l'hélicoptère en garde à
l'horizontale 54 pays survolés des
centaines d'heures d'enregistrement un
hommage à la planète mais surtout un cri
d'alarmé
le film dévoile une terre urbanisé à
outrance meurtri surexploitées au point
que ses ressources s'épuisent tandis que
l'atmosphère se réchauffe dangereusement
en sibérie le sol gelé qui contient des
donc quantité de co2 et de méthane
commencent à se liquéfier
ce permafrost fondeur
le dégagement de méthane provoquerait un
emballement de l'effet de serre dont nul
ne peut prévoir les conséquences
un emballement qui nous emmènerait vers
une terre inconnue
il aura fallu trois ans pour réaliser le
film trois années de tournage et de
rencontres je m'appelle compagne l'homme
qui voit le jour qui n'est pas répartie
home nous donne des nouvelles
inquiétantes de la planète sur des
images souvent magnifiques
c'est le pari de yann arthus bertrand un
film militant avoir comme un opéra
alors rien de ce film sera un cri
d'alarmé on le dit beaucoup vous aviez
déjà fait beaucoup de documents sur
france 2 il ya eu le film d'al gore
qu'est ce qu'il a de plus finalement ce
film ils vont à globaliser tout d'abord
c'est l'histoire extraordinaire de la
vie sur terre
le film n'est pas tout anxiogène la vie
c'est inouï comment la vie est arrivé ce
que dit barak vous êtes catastrophiste
un peu est-ce qu'on est assez grand pour
voir la vérité en face et ça l'idée mais
c'est l'histoire extraordinaire de la
vie et d'une espèce extraordinaire la
nôtre car il ya deux cent mille ans sur
la terre il ya quinze mille ans grâce à
un climat veut un climat tempéré
elle s'installe domestique la nature
pour en vanter l'agriculture et elle
fait les civilisations et ce qu'elle
fait est extraordinaire
le problème c'est que ce qui est
catastrophique c'est pas que ça va
arriver parce qu'on peut l'arrêter c'est
qu'un déni collectif personne ne veut le
voir
personne ne veut changer si on change
maintenant il ya pas de problème on va
continuer longtemps donc on peut parler
de tes ça allait on part à londres
bonsoir maryse burgot le film a déjà été
diffusé ce midi il le sera à nouveau ce
soir en plein coeur de londres à
trafalgar square je crois c'est cela oui
c'est assez magique de voir par exemple
les images du grand canyon au coeur de
la capitale britannique juste à côté de
big ben alors ma le malheureusement
aujourd'hui il ne fait pas très bon à
londres
mais cela n'a pas empêché les passants
de s'arrêter pour admirer les images de
ce film et surtout en écouter le propos
alors nous avons vu apparaître sur les
écrans géants les images les visages des
princes william et harry avec une
grenouille
parce que la grenouille est le symbole
de ces espèces menacées par le
réchauffement climatique nous avons vu
aussi le visage du prince charles
toujours avec une grenouille un humour
typiquement britannique pour dénoncer
entre autres la disparition des forêts
tropicales en fait comme yann arthus
bertrand
le prince charles l'héritier de la
couronne d'angleterre est un écologiste
très convaincu c'est pour cela qu'il a
accepté de participer à cette
manifestation via cet écran géant
merci maryse alors françois henri
pinault vous est venu dans une interview
que parfois on a des larmes aux yeux
quand on regarde ce document merci
beaucoup d'émotion tout à fait c'est un
film très émouvant à la fois parle
les images époustouflantes qu'iliad a
fait notre planète cette beauté même
dans des situations catastrophiques et à
la fois aussi une émotion de réaliser
parce que franchement réalise à travers
ce film ce qu'on a fait de cette planète
la situation dans laquelle on est donc
des émotions très diverses mais très
très forte
et à la fin c'est pour ça que je pense
que yann n'est pas catastrophique mais
réaliste un message d'espoir il n'est
pas trop tard donc des émotions très
varié très forte et des mythes des
images parfois difficiles à tourner et
on vous a supprimé parfois vos rush et
ça dans certains pays
le lin magar des 50% de nous de mes fils
me dubaï en a été renvoyé à paris dont
j'ai envoyé une équipe sous un faux nom
on aa procès en ce moment pour les
élevages intensifs qu'on a fait aux
états unis mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que grâce à toi ce film n'a pas
d'ambition commercial et ça c'est
quelque chose de nouveau pas de
copyright tout le monde peut le prendre
tout le monde peut le coq qui open où il
ya vingt mille dvd qui s'envole dans les
écoles
le gouvernement allemand en envoie dans
toutes les écoles en allemagne
borloo à acheter des copies qui lui a
donné aux préfets qu'il passe dans
toutes les villes de france je les fais
face à nicolas sarkozy pour qu'il ne
passe à barack obama demain exactement
c'est exactement ça c'est lui qui me l'a
demandé je revenais pas d'abord il a vu
le film à l'elysée d'abord il est resté
sur son siège devant deux heures ce que
tu es formidable il a regardé le film il
m'a dit le film est génial film allemand
est ce que je pourrais le passé au
président wade mais j'ai bien sûr donc
vous l'avez fait une copie spéciale en
anglais qui va donner aujourd'hui quand
vous parlez de décroissance c'est aussi
ça parfois aujourd'hui ont une
conscience qu'il faut accepter la
décroissance de moins consommer accepter
qu'on peut vivre mieux avec moi c'est
pas une grosse décroissance d'avoir un
petit peu moins aujourd'hui 40 % de la
nourriture te fait en europe et jeté
entre le début et nos poubelles c'est
pas normal il ya on vit dans un monde de
gâchis on dépense trop qu'en pense
l'homme d'affaires écoutez moi je me
suis engagé dans sud parce que je crois
qu'effectivement si on fait rien on sera
obligé de consommer moins d'eau et
l'histoire a montré que l'homme n'est
jamais capable d'aller en arrière moi je
crois que ce film montre aussi qu'on
peut consommer autrement
aix est de la responsabilité aussi des
entreprises de trouver d'apporter des
solutions pour consommer autrement et ce
pain fabriqué un nouvel avenir
on retrouve luc besson juste pour une
dernière question l'objectif c'est quoi
qu après avoir vu ce film ne soient plus
les mêmes que quelque chose
finalement et échanger en nous
oui vraiment bon il faut il faut qu'on
bouge ça c'est sûr je rappelle quand
même à tout le monde qu'on ne pourra pas
quitter la planète
on va être obligé de rester dessus on
peut pas partir donc il faut en prendre
soin c'est la seule planète qu'on a et
il faut en prendre soin au maximum merci
luc besson et puis bien évidemment on le
voit les parisiens pourront suivre ce
film effectivement à partir de 22 heures
sur france 2 dans quelques instants
il ya aussi un peu d'espoir dans tout
cela viala pourriez-vous cela pourrait
saper au possible quand même que de
l'espoir dans ce film sophie déjà pour
qu'on change donc bien sûr que d'espoirs
façon de vivre toute façon merci à tous
les trois le compte à rebours touche à
sa fin au bout c'est dans quelques
instants
mais avant cela rappelle de
l'information du jour c'est l'énigme
encore et toujours qui entoure la
disparition du vol 447 d'air france
puisque l'on a appris aujourd'hui que
les débris retrouvés hier par l'armée
brésilienne ne provienne finalement pas
de l'appareil côté français les
recherches se poursuivent également et
un sous-marin de l'armée devrait arriver
dans le périmètre des recherches dans le
courant de la semaine prochaine
voilà merci à vous d'avoir suivi journal
dans quelques instants donc home de yann
arthus bertrand est suivi d'une émission
spéciale j'allais dire comment sauver la
planète
présenté par l'excellent yves calvi et
puis on retrouvera bien évidemment la
météo tania young
demain dès 11h en direct sur france 2 il
ya beaucoup de choses ce week-end les
commémorations du 65e anniversaire du
débarquement en normandie avec marie
drucker je retrouve demain à 13 heures
et à 20 heures en compagnie à l'agora ni
la journaliste de cnn qui sera avec
meurt avec moi pour décrypter toutes les
images du jour voilà excellente soirée à
bout donc et à demain j'espère
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr